اكثر من لحظه من الكلام اللي أكبر من لحظه
وانت تغطي ميدانيا على المباشر كانوا
يطلبوا منكم السكوت والصمت عشان يسمعوا
اصوات تحت الانقاذ ينقذوها كيف كان شعورك
في هذه اللحظات
سهام هذا الموضوع لو تعطيني شويه دقيقه
اشرح لك هذا اكثر شيء بالنسبه الي مؤلم
يعني لو انا عدت الى عمان ما اكثر شيء
يدور في ذهني اكثر شيء يدور في ذهني انه
في شخص يكون تحت الانقاض ينادي ويصرخ
ويستنج ويستنجد ولا يسمع احد يعني تخيلي
انسان لما بيكون في بيته مثلا واغلق علي
باب بيته وما معاه تليفون وما حدا سامعه
الشعور ممكن ينجن اذا قاعد ايام ما حدا
سامعه ومش عارف يطلع من بيته مثلا محاصر
في بيته ما بالك بشخص تحت انقاض وركام
بدون ماء بدون كهرباء في برد قارص وشديد
كنت كل شخص اشوفه والتقي فيه من الناجين
اسالوا هذا السؤال اقول له بماذا شعرت
يعني احدى النساء قالت لي انت ميت حي انت
في القبر لكنك حي ولا يسمعك احد كثير من
الاحيان كانوا يطلبوا منا الصمت لانه يكون
في مؤشر على حياه انسان ولكن للاسف الشديد
في بعض الحالات
الحديد عنيد يعني كان اعند من اي اله يعني
حينما تستغرق عمليه الانقاذ لهذا الشخص
الحي ومتاكدين انه حي تستغرق مثلا اربع
ساعات او خمس ساعات